nice seeing you everyone uh finally a
live meetup i've been in uh well
for two years only the virtual ones
i'm kevin ostra i'm from netherlands
indeed and today my goal is to show how
castle inference can be made easy using
inverse propensity waiting
um yeah as i mentioned i'm from
netherlands uh
i don't know if everyone knows where it
is but i got this picture from wikipedia
so you've got europe and the small tiny
country in green that's nemens
i joined finance systems which actually
is in israel here at tel aviv
and i usually of course work from home
from harlem
but let's say you might think like why
did i join a company all the way in
israel and just because my main
interests are cultural inference
contextual bandits and machine learning
engineering in general and vinai allows
me to work on all those topics
and also the last point at drill running
between the zoom calls
i now after two years still doing while
everyone's going to the office
i can get some fresh air
in the dunes near harlem
a short word about vinai we're a company
building the world's first decision
optimization platform to reliably
prescribe validate and execute actions
that optimize business outcomes
it's a mouthful
in short
we're trying to build a platform
for businesses a self-service platform
in which they can
well self-serve causal influence
platform which truly optimizes outcome
outcomes so we're not just doing machine
learning in general we're trying to make
impact on the in the company
um yeah and as being a small company
we're still growing so you might
be interested or know someone please
leave me a message
uh well the topic of this talk is called
inference and how to solve it so i'll
first give a short introduction
why cause influence is worth solving and
then how i yeah in first perpetuating
actually is one of the solutions to it
um
yeah as an introduction if we look back
at the timeline of analytics we've done
uh initially
most analytics was done by creating
dashboards making charts plots
showing to the business
uh using correlation or using statistics
to actually get some numbers out of it
and a question we're answering is uh
what happened in the past we're just
looking backwards explaining what
happens
then machine learning came along
and we're looking at for example
nice pictures of dogs and cats you got a
picture you got a label you can learn
what the label is given the picture
what we're then actually doing is we're
looking at correlations there's some
correlation between the picture and the
label
we put
a paper on the label and then we can
predict what goes on
what's behind paper
what we're seeing now in the data
science community is that we're moving
towards prescriptive analytics
the idea is that we're not just looking
at correlations we're actually going to
look at the system how a system behaves
which events and actions cause other
events and actions
and then
using causal inference we can answer a
different question we're not
answering the question like given this
information what is the other
information i don't know yet we're
asking which action should i take what
should i do differently from what i'm
doing now to get a better result
to to give
give you a little bit more intuition
about what's the difference i
do here some example with you some
examples for example the predictive
approach on getting a new customer like
acquisition would be to answer the
question how likely is this customer
this prospect becoming a customer
well the prescriptive approach will be
to say would it help if i call this
person or would it help if i send him an
email or just give him a discount
regarding product engagement will this
user become a monthly active user
will yeah will he become a multi-active
user or what can i do
to improve the product engagement
sending an email does it improve his
engagement
related to churn
a lot of
companies are trying to predict the
churn like how likely is this person
going to churn but that's
that's a pretty
predictive approach the prescriptive
approach would say which which people
which customers should actually call to
prevent them from churning
yeah so in short well of course now i
think you're getting the guess the
difference between predictive and
prescriptive
in short it is with predictive approach
you keep the system and
like your
yeah your full system like your company
how it operates you keep it the same
and then you're going to predict what
will happen if you continue operating
like this idea of prescriptive approach
is that you're going to change some
things in the system which will cause
the correlations actually to change and
then you get different outputs different
outcome and one you prefer we want to
have
um
yeah so the goal of pulse inference is
to predict the effect of an action
given a known context and in short you
can answer questions like what if i do
well x what will happen and why will it
happen
or if you're looking at all data what if
i had done something else in the past
would have got another result now
there are different techniques to solve
this and the one i will cover today is
inverse propensity weighting
and the first to explain like why
inverse pension waiting actually solves
uh well is a solution to causal
inference i need to explain what
actually is difficult about calcium
inference
and so what i've drawn here is a causal
graph
the most simple one actually
so you got a user with some features
column of force x and there's some
results the churn ray the churn up
churning yes or no
processing
product engagements whatever you want
and we also have got a
so-called treatment the action we do we
sending emails giving and discounts all
those kind of things
and both of course influence results
already
mentioned
if we have a system like a company
operating there are all kinds of
correlations in the system and then
the thing is if we're looking at the
data if you collect a lot of features
and labels the only thing you can see
are actually the correlations
and with those correlations you can
build with whatever models maybe deep
learning you can build really predictive
models
so you get correlation does give you
predictive power
however
we're interested in this specific link
we're not interested in this one we want
to know like
what what is the effect of a treatment
on the result
and to do that we need uh so-called
cause yeah that's a prescriptive power
and that we need the causal link the
causation instead of the correlation
and the way i've drawn this causal graph
the correlation between the treatment
and the result is actually equal to this
single arrow which is also the causal
link so this this case correlation is
equal to causation
however in practice this graph usually
isn't the correct graph
and which p which people are you giving
a discount which people are you calling
usually there's some business process
some marketing campaigns some other yeah
some other rule-based system determining
which users will get certain treatments
and also the whole idea of this cult
inference is that we make a model which
will prescribe actions if we're going to
use that model in production
it will create it will specify which
treatments to do based on the features
so our future data set will always have
a dependency actually cause a link
between features and treatments
in this graph the correlation we observe
in the data between the treatment and
result is not anymore equal to the
causal link between the two
that's because there's
also a correlation between treatment and
the features and the correlation between
features and results so there are two
two correlated the two correlation paths
that's so called backdoor
and then we're only interested in this
single one
if you look at this system you could
still make a really predictive model
however the predictive model doesn't
become is a good prescriptive model
so now we're going to solve this
this case so there are two general
approaches or situations you can solve
it in
one approach is to start a so-called
random control style where you run an
experiment for a limited time
where you assign the treatments
completely random what you basically do
in short is you remove the link between
features and treatments and then
the correlation between treatment result
is again the causal link and you can use
any machine learning to learn the effect
it's simple straightforward
and of course correlation organic
causation the only issue is you're
running you're only learning during the
experiment you're throwing away all the
data before your experiment and you
won't use you can't use any data after
experiments
so of course the goal is in
using as much as possible much of the
data you have
and
yeah we all want to do big data right so
you just use all the data we have and
learn from that
so
the
the a better or more
maybe better better more interesting
problem to solve is to find out how we
can remove the bias
created by this correlation by this
vector correlation
and still be able to predict this causal
link
[Music]
yeah so
two advantages or one if we're going to
use all data and another advantage is
that we also will be able to use future
data which is really nice because then
every week or month or year we can
retrain the model and actually learn
from the actions we took
there are two
well two downsides is one is that you
actually need to know all these uh
so-called confounders these features in
the castle influence literature are
called confounders you need to know them
if you've got if you don't know them
you can't correct for them which is
quite tricky
and also another well risk or downside
is is that your system might be too
deterministic
if for example uh
in your customer acquisition you always
call all people
above 50 years and you always email all
persons below 50 years there's no way
your model can learn what an email does
for a 50 plus a person and what a call
will do for below 50 it never happens so
there's no way there's no information
about it
so you need to have some
probabilities some randomization in your
data
but it doesn't have to be like here
completely random
the general approach in
getting so called unbiased predictions
using observational data is first to
include all your confounders
and sometimes you actually the system
you're trying to model is quite easy or
your model is really good
and then you can have like a perfect
model if it is able to predict all the
nuances all the small changes you see
then actually you're already done
however usually
mostly you've got errors because not all
real-life systems are that easy to model
and then
[Music]
you can imagine it is that those errors
are mainly minimized for the
uh the policy which your model which a
company currently has
so today we're going to use inverse
benzene weighting to
ensure that these errors are
um
i say evenly distributed between your
policy and any arbitrary new policy
you think like if
if i would keep the system the same you
have the way you operate the people you
send an email then it's you you can have
quite a good predictive power
uh but what we want to do is take
different actions we want my we want to
send an email to other people than we're
currently doing to make make our policy
better
yeah
yeah of course that was better
so the question is if you include your
confounders
does it actually remove the bias
enough
and does it really remove the back door
no if you include them you don't
there
is open and it's still there it's there
and then whatever your model gives you
could be
bad results like the correlation can be
spurred might be experience
yeah so um
yes okay let me repeat the question
first
so if you add the confounders you can
you still have the back door in your
calls or graph so you can still have
wrong predictions
on your effect
and
what i see if you include the confiners
it's the same as again i've got it's not
stratification but it's uh
standardization i keep mixing
what you kind of do is you let your
model
stand or die you do stand apply
standardization which is different
technique so
kind of per
bin of your features like per area of
your feature space you can your model
can learn the mean uh
the mean outcome for treated and the
mean outcome for the non-treated and
have a non-biased group within a bin
like within a small area
and if it is able to do that for all
your areas
then you will have really low error like
your model is like practically accurate
and then networks are usually
when you just throw in the confounders
your model isn't able to do that
standardization completely correct
and then you will have errors and those
errors
the ensure your model tries to reduce
the average error
and the average error is always biased
towards your current policy because that
happens the most so you're saying if i
include the
confounders then
i can use the the accuracy of my model
to judge whether the backdoor hurts me
or not
yeah so if your models are like
practically perfect then you're already
done but
i never at least i usually don't have a
perfect mobile
yeah
yeah so then the
what
the errors you have those will you uh
won't be sure if the
you'll see some errors so you think i've
got a certain predictive error on the
outcome
um what actually those errors are the
the errors you can expect
if you would run the current policy
because it minimizes the current policy
is biased towards the current policy
but if you would do a different action
the expected error on the new action
might be higher than the error you see
in your trade set
it's kind of the
okay
so then infrastructure waiting may um
yeah will ensure that the errors are
random both across current policy and
alternative policies
and actually it's quite a it's quite a
simple technique so what we do with
universal propensity waiting is we
create a propensity model so we create a
preventive model which given the
features learns what the likelihood of a
treatment is
as an example like
you can imagine that we've got a certain
features
and for every range of feature okay of
course it's multi-dimensional but i
assume it's like a single dimensional
for some values you prefer one treatment
of the other and for other other values
it's the other way around
what we now actually do is we create a
model uh which will learn this curve
but then of course multi-dimensional
binary data sets
and the approach of first pensivating is
then to create
to predict the propensity of the
treatment you act
your sample and your data data set
actually got so you're looking at your
historical data
some users got a certain treatment you
predict the propensity that it got that
likelihood of getting that treatment
now we're going to create sample weights
for our
for the model we want to learn and the
sample weight is equal to one divided by
that same propensity
if we think if you look like
if you're thinking about a feature space
and at some places in the feature space
treatment one is more likely another
space is treatment two is more likely
and now we're gonna re-weight our data
sets so we got these like maybe a ratio
of ten to one a feature of treatment one
to two we're going to weight them
inversely so one is weighted down down
weighted by 10 and the other one is
elongated by one so actually the
likelihood within small sub areas will
be the same it's quite yeah
to verbally describe it it's quite
difficult
but it's kind of if you have this slope
and you divide we multiply the
yet
right it's propensity but think of it
like a frequency if you multiply by the
weight which also kind of
artificially creates a pseudo data set
with different frequencies you will get
a uniform of all treatments across the
full feature space
and then um there's no the idea is that
this had gives you no bias anymore
because there is no relationship anymore
between the features and your in our new
uh between our features and treatments
in our new pseudo data sets so we're
creating a computer data set by
re-weighting such that there's no
dependency anymore from feature to
treatment
so the cookbook or recipe in short is we
train propensity model we predict the
propensity for all observed treatments
and then we can train an outcome model
using
typical machine learning approaches
however we
weight our samples by the inverse
propensity we got from the previous step
but then
i can
tell you this and you might believe me
or not but the question of course is
does it work
so
as a test case i created a bias data set
so we got
our calls a graph again
i created a simple relationship between
features and results which is
linear
i created an interesting treatment
effect being this v-shape
and i also created a certain selection
by a treatment selection between having
an influence from features to treatments
being this sigmoid so it's the y-axis
it's probability of getting a treatment
if you combine this and create some
samples
it looks like this is it still uh
one-dimensional
the blue dots are the non-treated and
the orange ones are treated
so you see it's like kind of the you see
the v as a small delta on top of the
non-treated values
and what we're now going to do is that i
choose a model which is this linear
model and we're going to use this loss
function root mean square because it's a
regression and one try to fit this
you already see that the the treatment
has a constant
in front of it
so we already know it won't be able to
represent the outcome perfectly of
course you can make a more complex model
but the idea is
whatever system there is in real life
your model might not be complex enough
to really represent it so i now took
really simple data set and then ensured
that my model is
well
reasonably well equipped to predict the
outcome but it's not fully uh
they're fully capable of doing so
and then our effects like the effect of
treatments is just uh
i would say if if we haven't if we have
trained the model we can just create two
predictions one with the treatment
variable being uh true and one with
treatment valuable false and subtract
the two from each other
and so that goes both
both the feature set both the feature
and the treatment are in the linear
linear regression
and we just subtract the two and then we
get our treatment effects
and this approach but we're using a
single model to learn so it's also known
as the s learner
if we train this model
it will not will never be able to
represent of course the v shape but
so it's it's it's just not capable of
doing it but with a room
root mean square error loss function
what we expect is to see is that like uh
it will predict the mean like the
average treatment effect
because ruby's error optimizes the mean
so we would expect it to also predict
like the mean treatment effect across
the full feature space
however
from the average of this v value is
around here while our model's estimate
is like there is a disk space
and this bias is due to the confounders
so following the cookbook we're going to
create a provincial model
and then ideally your prevention model
is again almost 100 perfect but usually
it isn't so i deliberately made my
prancing model a bit too biased
um the blue dots is the ground truth or
the propensity of the treat of the
likelihood of getting a treatment and
orange one is what the model says of
course in practice you don't have the
blue line so you don't know
how well that fits but what you can do
is you can make this calibration plot
where where you
you predict all the propensities you
take the bin for example around
10
you should take all samples within the
10 bin and what you expect to see is 10
positives within that bin
and you just create a plot of that and
then you see that for the lower bins
it's a
overestimates the value and for the
higher bins it underestimates it so then
you can just adjust it by a small yeah
removing the bias by correcting
correcting those bins
and then you can do for example
crossfelt predicts and you get the
actual uh
texture propensities so then the
propensities are actually true
probabilities and then if you again
create a calibration plot
it's much better
and so i can learn as your standard the
calibration functions to be able to do
this
and also the plots
um well then we've got our propensities
next step divide one divide one divided
by
then we see our pennsylvania problem if
we divide something uh
one by something which is quite small
we'll on the limit go to infinity
so you've got a really rare rare case in
your data set
and
it will get infinite weight and your
whole model will just learn that single
point that's not really
that we cannot see that does it will not
work out there are two approaches one is
to clip the value so you say well any
value above 0.95 or below 0.05 we just
set it to
that boundary
another approach is that you say well
actually
these extreme propensities tell me that
in these areas of feature space i don't
have enough
enough noise no not another
randomization
so actually
my model probably isn't really good in
predicting what happens there i might
need to do some if we still do an
experiment for this area and just throw
them out of my data set for now
so that would mean setting the weight to
zero
uh let's go back so if uh
if we re-weight our samples with the
first plenty weights
we just created and then we train the
same linear model
we actually get the green dots and it's
nice perfect on top of the true average
treatment effect
so it shows at least in this case
it really works
um well the the steps have been expanded
a bit so we've got train propensity
model calibrate them
predictive propensity for observed
treatments
then do some clipping mechanism
and only then step five we can train the
outcome model
uh on inverse plenty weighted samples
uh
some final remarks is well at least i
hope you can take this uh can take this
home
is if you have really good if you have
some
predictive quality on your outcome it
doesn't per se mean you also have
prescriptive power because of the bias
and the reason is if you train your
model on
well biased
data train set your validation and test
that are also biased so it actually
performed really well on other buyer
systems if you're gonna put your
prescription in production you're gonna
create different samples with different
distributions and then suddenly you see
big errors
next point is you always need some
randomization if it's too deterministic
you can't learn anything
i think you'll repeat it already a few
times
and another thing
is that your potential actually doesn't
need to be
perfect mainly the reason to have the
principle model mainly is to represent
those confounders
so finding extra features which help you
predict a better propensity actually can
make
actually removes the efficiency of the
parenthesis model the idea is that it
should focus on the confounding
variables
uh of course this is only a short talk
and uh
i can i can only cover a little bit of
the material so actually there are two
blog posts i've written about this topic
one is understanding first pencil
weighting another is preventing churn
like a bandit
i of course recommend those
next to that there are two books i
really recommend one is support the book
of why from judeo pearl which is more
culturally influenced in general
another one you might have not heard of
is cultural influence what if which is
just an online opensort book which
really explains you how all techniques
work
including standardization stratification
first pensive weighting and many more
and for a quick explanation of many
algorithms economel has done a quite a
good job explaining
actually they implemented a lot of
algorithms and also have done a really
good job of writing them down how they
work and actually why they work
and hear it now
so
that was it any more questions yeah of
course
this is an old problem with some
selection by us which statistician did
many in the competition
win a nobel prize for solving
this assumption based on strong
parametric assumptions
jack manske proved that in
cases of sample selection biases
there is
no magic word if you don't have
information in your data to estimate not
inverse propensity not anything will
help you to estimate the real treatment
effect and this is the issue which i
cannot mission uh engage with it a lot
it's not that you have a magic
solution ah then i would have gotten i
would have got a nobel prize
then i would
the professor
every year many uh offer
referring to nobel prize but
george anguish his friends will not
reply this exactly on those problems and
he proves that if you don't have any
information sample selection bias
there is only uh very
high bounds to the probability real
probability of response if you use your
models on other population which don't
distribute as the big data that you have
i'll give you an example credit scoring
i developed once the model of credit
score
the most
significant variable was unemployed
the model said they are the best risks
yes so this is buyers of course invited
by us because
the credit card company didn't give
credit
to bid to build unemployed only if they
have another information which we don't
see in the data
so how is your model can predict
from
no data that unemployment is the best
operation
that's exactly okay i'll try to
summarize it
i'll try to summarize your question
how can you predict this if you data
doesn't actually show the information
yeah of course you can't and i i think
the summary is in my uh point of it's
not being it shouldn't be too
deterministic if your credit scoring uh
system of your yet the cred the credit
company never gave loans to unemployed
people
there's no way to know for which
unemployed people
a good credit would it wouldn't work so
then you need of course you need to run
some experiments
if you want to learn it well if it's
worth the price fico and others use your
method on
classical statistics uh
they call it augmentation credit scoring
but they again doesn't solve the problem
of no information i don't know
i totally agree if you don't have
information your model can learn it but
what i do see trends that
typically in econometrics and
statisticians
use certain models to train and to
actually predict effect
usually there were like
specific parameterized models we also
see in the data science community it's
all like just throw in as big as
possible neural network
throw in a manual feature generation and
just make it work so
the power of machine learning allows you
to express a lot of dependencies however
the bias still exists and of course you
need information
and what i like from my first pension
weighting and that's it's a way to bring
the power of deep learning and all other
techniques we have cut boost whatever
into the more uh classical area of uh
more linear regressions and then those
assumptions this is the okay
so sorry sorry but i also want to give
someone else opportunity maybe we can
just continue discussion
over a beer or something else
are there any more questions
yeah
are there any statistical tests
if you're taking the frequencies for
example i'm sorry patients
are there any statistical tests for how
good is my modeling
what is my problem my prescriptions
um
it's quite difficult
but i think you were aiming at like if
you created your model like this how do
you know
uh
if it actually works
so then um you come in an area of uh
so-called offline policy evaluation so
we we just created a
tried to create an unbiased predictor we
are given treatment so we know this
treatment will have a positive effect or
not and then based on that we'll give
the treatment yes or no but if you have
a data set you can actually look at
those test data and see
for every row would i have given the
same treatment as the person actually
got
and if i didn't well then i wouldn't
have seen this in my
experiment because i wouldn't treat this
person so i will not see this sample
like it occurs
uh see okay if i have a person
in my test set who got treatment a and
my policy says i should give him
treatment b
um
in if i would run my my policy in
production i wouldn't see this record
because he got the wrong treatment so i
can throw it out
and then you go along like go through
your old test set like this so you throw
out all samples which don't agree with
your policy
it's called agreement set
and then you get an estimate on
it's like one estimate on your policy
quality so you can actually see if i
would have run
this product this policy production this
is kind of the results i would have got
to gotten
it is
one caveat is that of course the
the the size
like the number of records we actually
match your new policy depends on your
previous policy so you actually do
something which
is called important sampling which is
kind of the same as being first-person
waiting but it's uh
something to google i think and
but there are some ways and then you can
do
also mentioned like a certainty so then
i waste like bootstrapping to get get
some sense
but of course the only true
uh
yeah
true way to find out if it really works
is
put it in production and maybe do like a
b testing comparing previous policy in
your new policy but at least you've got
like an initial guess of what your
policy would perform probably and then
you can verify it
i hope it then you you could you said
earlier to approach the ict and the
randomized yeah and observations so yeah
the right way is always very wasteful
because you can use your previous
experience you can improve it in the
future and so on
but suppose you have a very big big data
a lot of potential do not click
starter clinical trial looking at this
but again you have a big company lots of
customers lots of uh
treatments you can now offer so
would you somehow compare them to uh
you suppose
you don't mind
uh um
you could you could
uh
do both so if you have done already like
a random experiment then you can see if
it aligns a bit with what you see when
you use observational data to get some
more confidence before you put your new
newly trained ibw model into production
um
there's always a risk that reality is
different from what you've seen and it
also depends on how much your new policy
is different from your existing policy
uh so
i would recommend like doing all these
comparisons as much as possible like
bootstrapping to get some idea of the
confidence how stable is your model
actually if some if you
is the performance you get just based on
the random test of random train set you
selected and then
yeah do an experiment but then not do a
random experiment do experiment with
your new policy which you think is
better so you already have some
confidence in it being better and then
you can slowly
move more towards your new policy
i think we're done with questions
thank you
you